في البرلمان الإسرائيلي الأسبوع الماضي، الغضب يغلي
لن تجلسوا هنا بينما
يموتون هناك هذا الرجل
يصرخ أفراد عائلة الرهائن في
غزة وهم يقتحمون جلسة في
الكنيست قائلين كفى
ميراف غونين لم تكن سياسية أبدًا الآن
وهي منتظمة هنا تدفع
المشرعين  لفعل كل ما يلزم
لإعادة ابنتها رومي البالغة من العمر 21 عامًا و
131 رهينة آخرين إلى الوطن، رأينا هذه
الأحداث مؤخرًا هنا في الكنيست
حيث كان أفراد الأسرة
يصرخون على السياسيين، هذا هو
الإحباط الذي تعرفه الناس عندما
يكونون في خوف  والإحباط، من
الصعب جدًا ضبط النفس، البعض
منا قد يبكي أكثر، ربما تعلم ذلك قريبًا من
الداخل والبعض منا يحتاج فقط إلى الصراخ،
وأنت تعلم أن الصراخ الصراخ
هو شيء يجب أن يكون CET قادرًا على
احتوائه أيضًا لأنه طويل جدًا  كان
أوماري، ابن شيل البالغ من العمر 21 عامًا، يعمل
كنادل ويوفر المال للسفر حول العالم
عندما تم اختطافه في
مهرجان موسيقى سوبر نوفا، إنه مشمس، إنه
صبي يريد الجميع أن يكونوا بالقرب منه،
الجميع يحبه، يحب أن يحبه.
تحب
الموسيقى ليلة السبت، فقد حضرت
اجتماعًا حاشدًا للرهائن كما تفعل كل
أسبوع، مرهقة ومحبطة ولكنها
لم تردع في سعيها لإعادة عمر إلى
المنزل. لا أعرف إذا كنت أمًا،
لذا حاولي أن
تتخيلي، حاولي أن تتخيلي أن
ذهب ابنك إلى
مهرجان
يريده فقط
مهرجان، يمكنك الاتصال بابنك الآن
لتسأله أوه، هل
تعرف أين ينام ابنك
الليلة، لا
أعرف لا بد أنه
عذاب أين
نحن
متعبون لكننا نفعل كل شيء، هذا هو
دورنا  مهمة حياتنا هي إعادة ابني إلى
المنزل، يجب على الجميع أن يقولوا
توقفوا، توقفوا، هل تشعرون أنه
تم
فعل ما يكفي، هل تشعرون بالرضا عن
الرد، استمعوا إلى ابني ليس في المنزل
كل يوم أدخل إلى غرفته
وهو  ما زال لا
ينام في سريره، لذا إذا كان هذا
كافيًا، فهذا ليس
كافيًا، فهو غير
كافٍ بعد
115 يومًا من هذا الكابوس، الصبر
والوقت ينفد